2023 has been a wild year for Hollywood
just as it started to recover from a
worldwide pandemic the writers and
actors went on strike so maybe it's not
surprising that there have been more
than a few box office bombs this year or
maybe it was because the movies weren't
as good regardless today I'm taking a
look at some of the biggest flops of
2023 so far DC tried to Hype The Flash
as one of the best things it's ever
released which probably doomed it to
fail at least somewhat right yeah it was
part of their attempt to rival Marvel in
the superhero world and well the results
weren't what they were hoping for now to
be fair the term flop is used pretty
broadly at this point because a few
years back you probably wouldn't have
looked at a movie that had Rotten Tomato
scores of 63% for critics and 83% for
fans and assume it did well and you look
at the fact that it made 68 million
bucks more than it cost to make and say
hey nice job but to the studios that's a
big flop cuz it's all about about
projected numbers people and they were
definitely projecting a lot more for the
flash plus the ongoing legal and mental
health issues of its star Ezra Miller
might have been a factor as well
Transformers rise of the beasts is
another one that might seem on the
surface like it did pretty well after
all it grossed $427 million at the box
office around the world and cost under
$200 million to make but by Transformers
standards that was pretty bad what's
interesting is that it actually had
better reviews than most of its
predecessors it's possible people are
just kind of over the franchise there
have certainly been a lot of movies in
the Transformers Universe there was also
the fact that it was a pretty crowded
summer in terms of releases so maybe it
got a little lost in the shuffle either
way the less than Stellar numbers are
making people wonder if Paramount will
move forward with more of them though
there might be some buzz and box office
help from the upcoming crossover movie
between Transformers and GI Jo go or
that one will be right back on this list
next year here's another head scratcher
the latest in the mission impossible
franchise has got fantastic reviews
hello 96 and 94% scores on Rotten
Tomatoes but that hasn't led to a baffo
box office take part of that is how much
it cost the studio to make they shelled
out $300 million for Tom Cruz's dive
back into his Ethan Hunt character so
when it grossed 491 million that wasn't
enough of a profit for anyone to be
happy the other is that it was released
right when the Barbie and Oppenheimer
movies came out and had trouble
competing against that Viral twer though
it's still in a lot of theaters and
could earn more it's trending too hard
in the wrong direction to turn the ship
around if you watch the trailer for
Indiana Jones in the dial of Destiny he
might have done a double take young
Harrison Ford what in the name of Han
Solo is going on here CGI gimmicks aside
the movie was fairly well received by
critics and audiences and and it managed
to bring in more money than a lot of the
big summer releases so why on Earth is
it on our list of the biggest flops of
the year Well it needed to earn $600
million to break even for Disney's
investment the film itself didn't cost
that much but when you add in the
marketing budget Etc it cost them a
pretty penny maybe like with
Transformers the franchise has just hit
its saturation point and fans aren't
sprinting to the theater to see how Dr
Jones is fairing in his later years or
even his flat backy earlier years of
course with Harrison's age it was
probably unlikely there were going to be
more Indiana Jones movies at least not
with him as Indiana The Little Mermaid
was another one of those hardto believe
flops based on the box office numbers
alone it earned 560 million around the
globe which I don't know feels like a
lot of money but like with Indiana Jones
Disney sunk a ton into marketing and
production The Little Mermaid reportedly
needed to cross the $500 million mark
just to recoup its expenses so that
means The Little Mermaid essentially
netted 63 million which isn't so great
for that big of an investment part of it
may have been that people weren't as
Keen to see a live-action version of The
Beloved animated film and then there was
a lot of controversy AKA racism about
the casting of a black female as aiel so
maybe that kept people away I hope not
the Covenant is at least an example of a
movie that earns significantly less than
it costs to make a Ka an actual flop the
guy Richie helmed military drama was
made for about $55 million but only
brought in 20 million the reviews and
audience ratings were actually really
great plus ask your friends who served
in the military and they'll likely tell
you it's one of the more realistic
movies in terms of what things are
actually like but maybe that realism
ultimately kept people away heartthrob
Jake Gyllenhaal is usually a solid bet
when it comes to getting butts in the
theater seats but that didn't happen
this time around if you haven't even
heard of Ruby Gilman teenage Kraken
you're probably not alone this animated
movie definitely got buried under a pile
of other summer releases and it was a
firm flop while it was cheap compared to
other Blockbusters it still didn't come
close to making money the studio
reportedly only spent about $70 million
making it and added another 70 million
in marketing and promotion so that meant
it needed to bring in $140 million just
to break even unfortunately that $70
million of marketing and promotion
didn't exactly do its job because Ruby
Gilman teenage Kraken only made 40
million bucks so at a loss of $100
million we can definitely put this one
in the Flop category it had decent
reviews and audience reactions so I have
to assume people were just busy seeing
other movies that appealed to them more
but they certainly weren't seeing
haunted mansion this was another genuine
flop and Disney is likely not feeling
great about it as one of their late
summer offerings it cost them 157
million bucks to make and based on its
initial numbers it was looking to be a
major flop but as the year has gone on
it's managed to make around 115 million
so still not great definitely hasn't
made its money back and certainly not
making Disney any money despite a fun
voice cast and the fact that it's based
on a ride that kids have loved for
decades at Disneyland it just didn't
appeal to people though In fairness it
has a Rotten Tomatoes audience score of
84% so at least people who saw it seemed
to enjoy it but others were likely
turned away by the critical reception
which was a dismal
37% either way it seems unlikely that
we're going to see a haunted mansion to
anytime soon if you talk to most people
who actually saw Dungeons and Dragons
honor among Thieves you'll probably hear
really good things it's one of those
movies that kind of came out of nowhere
and while you might assume that a movie
based on this classic game would have a
hard time living up to the years of fun
people have had playing it the movie
actually came together brilliantly both
fans and critics raved about Dungeons
and Dragons honor among Thieves with 93
and 91% scores respectively on Rotten
Tomatoes and again this was a movie that
actually made money it was made for 150
million bucks and brought in 27 million
so you might think the studio would be
happy but when the actual product is so
good and people people who see it love
it the expectation is that it'll net a
ton more so by that standard it was a
flop Shazam Fury of the Gods was
released early this year and it was
expected to live up to the standard set
by the first shazam movie as it turns
out that was going to be pretty much
impossible Shazam the original cost
about 90 million bucks to make and
brought in about 370 million yeah that's
a lot more the sequel not so much it
managed to rake in around 132 million
which was only a touch more than the 125
million it cost them to make audiences
did seem to dig it but critics weren't
impressed and the fact that the star
Zachary Levi posted some controversial
statements on social media with regard
to vaccination could have also kept
people away hopefully the remainder of
2023 will see some quality options and
the flops will be behind us I know when
the holidays hit there's nothing I like
better than a trip to the theater you
ever mix M&M's right inside the popcorn
bag it's a game changer anyway did you
see any of these 2023 flops which ones
deserve to do better at the box office
let us know in the comment section